either you're a meat eater or you're a
vegetarian so I wondered
might there be a third solution I
thought about it and I came up with one
and I've been doing it for the last year
and it's great it's called weekday veg
the name says it all
nothing in the face Monday to Friday
on the weekend your choice it's
structured so it ends up being simple to
remember
and it's okay to break it here and there
after all cutting five days a week is
cutting seventy percent of your meat
intake the program has been great I'm
healthier I know that I'm going to live
longer my footprint's smaller
I'm lessening pollution
I feel better about the animals I'm even
saving money what's stopping you from
giving wake Dave Edge a shot
after all
if all of us ate half as much meat
it would be like half of us were
vegetarians